Why is David fincher?
In my head,
I was thinking about this a lot while
watching his new netflix series,
mind hunter,
I'd watch an episode or to go to the
kitchen to get a drink and everything
would look.
Fincher,
ask like my eyes were mimicking his
camera movement somehow.
First I was creeped out,
then I was impressed and then it was
curious what about his filmmaking causes
this effect because there are plenty of
other amazing stylistic directors whose
visual styles don't hijack your census
like venture does,
and it's the same with all his movies
and TV shows.
I checked,
I went back through all of them to see
if I could locate the source of this
quality and I think I found it here.
Did you see that?
It's a very small thing and it's easy to
miss,
but the more I watched fincher's work,
the more it stands out as a key element
of his visual language.
What is it exactly?
Well,
it's a camera move.
In this case,
the tilt,
in this case,
a pan in this case,
a tracking shot,
and in this case all three these things
are the most common tools and the
filmmakers toolbox.
You can find them in pretty much any
film you watch,
but fincher has a very specific way of
using them which falls in line with his
reputation as a perfectionist.
Essentially what he tries to do is have
the camera exactly match the velocity
and direction of the moving character in
the frame.
When the character stops,
the camera stops and starts again.
When the person starts to move again,
but the matching movement here isn't
just clothes.
It's perfect,
so perfect.
In fact,
that it must involve some kind of time
to rehearsal with the actors,
which I learned when I tried to do it
myself earlier.
This is no doubt a part of the reason
why fincher is known for doing so many
takes.
It takes patience and a good camera
operator to get these moves exactly
right and they're happening all the
time,
everywhere in little shots in between
shots,
shots.
You notice in shots you don't and
whether they register or not,
the effect starts to accumulate in your
mind.
All of a sudden fincher's reality is
your reality.
Now,
I think there's a very good reason why
this happens and it's a bit
counterintuitive when you consider that
fincher's camera work is often regarded
as impersonal or coldly omniscient even
by fincher himself,
and I think that's somewhat disingenuous
because what these shots do is
effectively lock you in to the behavior
of the characters.
You really feel it when someone moves
around the space that they're in.
Even small gestures like a shrug or
deflated shoulders.
Even the slightest change in posture is
registered by this camera.
In this way.
I think pinterest cinematography is a
lot more personal than even he makes
out.
It might happen just below the level of
consciousness,
but a much more in sync with this
character than I am with,
for example,
this character.
It's funny,
fincher's actors have to move in these
very deliberate lines at steady speed's
probably ironed out by rehearsal,
but the result,
at least for me,
is a greater connection to the character
than something that is more free form.
Less exact.
I mean,
it's no surprise that fincher would pay
attention to details like this.
Listen to the advice he gave Robin
Wright when she directed her first
episode of House of cards.
Every scene you direct,
every scene you act in,
it's the same thing.
What's that?
He said,
behavior over time,
it's a fraction.
So behavior is the most important thing
of every piece of material that you
read,
that you performance and you direct.
Look at the behavior,
David.
Fincher is obsessed with behavior.
He knows that the way a person moves is
a key part of who they are and what they
want.
He knows that if a person is running and
the camera follows that running exactly,
then it's like the audience is running
too.
He knows that the truth of aspiration is
in the speed.
Someone lurches forward.
He knows that fear can express itself in
exactly how slow someone stands up or
that when a person floats back in
astonishment,
the camera should follow up with them.
It's not a coincidence that emotion has
the word emotion.
Emotions express themselves physically.
What fincher does is put his camera in
lock,
step with the body to capture that
physicality,
and as a result,
we developed this almost unconscious
connection with these characters,
but the trick works almost too well.
You start to notice behavior and
movement in the real world,
but in the way that fincher stages then
deliberate,
steady and precise for a little while.
At least David fincher hijacks your
eyes.
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching my video
on fincher.
If you want to learn more about him,
I definitely recommend watching my
friend Tony's video on what he doesn't
do,
his movies,
which is super interesting.
Also,
Captain Christian did something on the
invisible digital effects in venture
films.
I'll link both of those below.
Definitely watch those.
This episode of the nerd writer was
brought to you by squarespace.
If you want to make a website and you
want it to be just a really easy
process,
squarespace has some beautiful award
winning designer templates to choose
from.
That makes that process super simple.
It's got 24 hour customer service,
no upgrades,
nothing to install,
no patches ever,
and picking your domain name is really,
really easy to.
You can start your free
trial@squarespace.com,
and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
definitely use that offer code.
You can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next time.